Hello believe nation. I started the mentor me series with the goal [to] try to hang around people
who've done a lot more than us learn from their success soak in a little bit more of their mindset and beliefs and how they
Operate and you know the environment is so important that the more you can hang around these people
Hopefully some of that seeps into you to make you the best version of yourself [so] today
We're going to get motivated with Sylvester Stallone mentor me Sylvester
What in this whole world turns you on?
Challenge, I really just I just love I love it. You know. I love being told no
It just means yes
No to you. Yeah, what turned you off?
Lack of Enthusiasm really turns me off like I don't care what your grandfather. Thinks about me, okay? All I care [about] is you
Now you lost back [there] because you beat yourself you let yourself get beat. I knew you can do it. Your a special kid
You're my boy. Do you understand but you're also a spoiled rich brat? Who's always had everything done for him now
It's time to do for yourself Mike, and you can do it because I'm telling you the world meets nobody halfway
Do you understand what that means if you want a drink?
You gotta take it. Do you have it you?
Go in there, and try I know you can win
But even if you don't so what so you lose as long as you lose like a winner
It doesn't matter because you did it with dignity. [I'm] telling you if you don't go in there. You're gonna be sorry
You're gonna regret it your whole life. You know what I mean
Come on. I know you can do it you do it for me
Gone, it's [Kid]
Let's start from the beginning [was] there ever a time that you [doubted] yourself. [yeah], you know
I thought when I you know I lived in this basically as flophouse [its] [twenty] [six] dollars a week very transient
And you [shared] [a] floor with ten people you don't know anybody on the planet literally know it?
I think I recall you saying you're acting low point [the] godfather, and you said you couldn't even get into
I couldn't be your [casas] in Italian
I'll never forget where there's a party seat is it [three] [hundred] guests like a hug said no I go
What part of me didn't make pass the Italian?
Identification aspect to go I don't know you just don't fit in
God is telling me something. It's gonna play with your pSyChe a little bit a little bit
No, yeah, but but it didn't and you decided to take matters into your own hands by writing
Yeah, Rocky you know. [I'll] just coming in for six years six years you've been sticking it to me. I wanna know how come
You wanna know?
I wanna know!
Okay, I'm gonna tell you cause you have the talent to become a good fighter a good fighter and instead of that you became a raving you were
able to write Rocky in three and a half days
The movie that went on to be best picture you wrote in three and a half days
Yes was it just flowing out of him anyway
It was I knew that this was going to be very flawed
but if I [could] get from the beginning to the [end] with some semblance of a character
Then I'll repair the rest along the way and you want to star in it, and you're told
No
You mean you even offer two hundred fifty thousand three hundred and sixty?
Renison your struggling actor who you you can't make ends meet you
Can you're getting offered all this money, but you didn't take it no?
I just didn't understand how the rules of life were played at that point, but this character, [I] understood
What's your point? My [point] is I'm pursuing something and nobody looks too. Happy about it
But. we're just looking out for your interests. I appreciate that but maybe you're looking out for your interests. [just] a little bit more
I mean, you should be asking people to come down here and pay the freight on something. They paid it still ain't good enough
I mean you think that's right. [I] mean maybe you're doing your job, [but] why you [gotta] stop me from doing mine?
because if you're willing to go through all the battle and you got to go through to get to where you want to get
who's got the right to stop you. [I] mean
Maybe some of you guys got something you never finished something you really want to do something
You never said to somebody something and you're told no even after you pay your dues
Who's got the right to tell you that who nobody its your right to listen to your gut and ain't nobody's right to say
No after you earn right could be where you want to be a do what you want to do?
You know the older I get the more things I [gotta] leave behind that's life
The only thing I'm asking you guys to leave on the table is what's right? I am a messenger
[I've] always believed that kind of a teacher. I've been down. I've been poor I've
I've been the lowest
Person [could] be in [this] business and come up, so I've seen every facet of it
So don't ever the word impossible should go out as I am a living testimony that miracles do exist
Through hard labor and dedication if I had to rewind the clock ten years I would [have] insisted
by people that it might close to me that
Please push me into very unsafe process at least every other one. [I] think it's it's
professionally responsible to to not
Continue to remake the same group over Kentville
What's tonight [turkey] TV dinner turkey TV dinner Jimmy don't think about this when you start and treat me?
I'm not doing Okie, sir. Not crazy at all if I could take everything that was good and [put] it into a bowl or something
And say hey here, I'd like to buy one [more] day with my wife I do it
Everything I got is moved on and I'm here I
never wanted to do this movie I a
Sick Rakhi is so counterintuitive to what Rakhi really is
Designed for I just [lay] that's akin someone else be sick in the movie and not me because I've never done that
My wife is your coward no one you know. It's kind [of] a harsh word
He goes no no, it's your yellow basically you're a coward it goes against every undeclared
Artistic rule if you're afraid of something that's the commitment of that of the artist, that's his duty
To pursue the unknown to go someplace where he's literally at odds with himself [right] [there] [woman]. Yeah
You know if you look hard enough, you can see your whole life will appear. How does it look?
He said he knew his whole life what he want to do since he's very very young he wanted to be in the movie business
Period I mean not [just] TV movies, and he said why was for him
It was a chance to have people not only escape
But to inspire people [and] by the way that drive is what made most of his movies [inspired] people to what they're capable of overcoming
Believable obstacles because in his own life he felt like he did that when he was born he's pulled out by the forceps
That's why he looked the way he did
That's why he talked to he did and he said so I really want to do that
And he said I knew why I want to do it
I wasn't [one] to settle [for] anything else, and [he] said what happened was I went out to try and get jobs
And it's not like I went her dream. They want you you're a star. It didn't work out real well
They looked at me and said hey, you're stupid look and do something else. You know
With cookie look is there's no place for you in that stuff. You're never [gonna] be a star in the movies
You're insane. No one's gonna [wanna] listen to somebody looks [dobie] and talks out of the side of their mouth
Right and got no after no after [no] after no. He said I was thrown out more fit more than
1,500 times of agents offices in New York. I said there are [15-minute] agents in New York
I said I know I've been on five six seven eight nine times
He said number one guy went in there, and I got in there at four o'clock, and he wouldn't see me
So I stayed there, and I would not leave I stayed overnight. They came back next morning. I'm still sitting there
He's that's why I got my first job the guy [said] [point] come in here
And he sat down and he went through this and he gave my first movie. So really I thought locky [first] mom
He said now this other movie. I never heard of it
He said I said [well], what character you play so I was in it for about 20 seconds
[I] was a thug somebody beat up
He said because they made me feel like you know some of the people hate your guts you getting beat up
It'll be a good thing, and he did like three movies like that
Never got anything kept going out rejection rejection rejection, so finally realized it wasn't working [so] [he] changed his approach
He said I was starving by the way
he said I couldn't pay for even to have heat in my
Apartment my wife was screaming at me everyday to go get a job. I said well
Why didn't you he said cuz I knew that if I got a job?
He said I'd get seduced back and I'd lose my hunger
He said I knew the only way I could do this is if it was the only choice if I burned all of the bridges
Because if I did a normal job pretty soon
I'd be caught up in that rhythm that stuff when I feel okay about my life
And I feel like my dream would just gradually disappear
He said I wanted to keep that hunger that hunger was the only thing I thought was my advantage
He said my wife didn't understand that at all. He said we have these vicious fights. He said it was freezing
So I was broke we had no money
And he said, so I finally went to the public library one day because it was warm
So I don't want to read anything since I went in New York Public library
I was hanging out there, and I sat [on] this chair and somebody left a book there and
he said I looked at this book [and] [over] the poems of Edgar Allan stories of Edgar Allan Poe and
He said so I started reading it. He said I got totally in the other growlin polity so I know everything [about] it
He goes on for another 20 minutes. Tell me about [it] [girl]. He knows everything how he died what it was about
What really happened? [I] said [well] would have poe do for you. He said poe got me out of myself
He got me to think about how I could touch other people not worry about myself so much
And he said [maybe] decide to become a writer
[I] said just iMagine Rocky the writer, right?
And he said so I tried to write a bunch of screenplays nothing work nothing to work. I were totally broke
He said I didn't even have [fifty] bucks, and he said and finally
He said I sold a script it was called Paradise alleys as a movie
I made many years later, but I sold it. He said I sold it for a hundred bucks
He said, but a hundred bucks was a ton of money man
I was so thrilled I thought I'm on my way, but it never led to anything
He said so finally he said I kept going and going going. He said finally we were so broke
He said I hocked my wife's jewelry. He said Tony. There's some things in [life]. You should never do
He said that was basically the end of our relationship. She hated my guts so much. He said now
We were so broke we had nothing no food no money, and he said the one thing
I love most in the world was my dog. He said I love my dog because he gave me unconditional love unlike my wife
And he said so what happened was though we were so broke good to survive
I couldn't even feed my dog so I went to a liquor stores there was the lowest day of my life
And [I] stood outside the liquor store trying to sell my dog to strangers
So I tried to sell my dog for 50 bucks
And he said this finally there's one guy negotiated with me and bought my dog for me my best friend and [ours] for $25
He said I walked away from there, and I cried he says the worst thing that ever happened in my life
He's a two weeks later. I'm watching a fight between muhammad Ali and wepner this white guy that's getting bludgeoned, but just keeps on coming
And he said I [got] an idea. He said as soon as the fight ended I started writing
He said I wrote for 20 straight hours. I did not sleep
I wrote the entire movie in 20 hours straight right then saw the fight wrote the movie whole thing done
He said I was shaking at the end. I was so excited, so I really knew man
I knew what I wanted I knew why I wanted he said just like you teach that formula
He said, but I said man, I [took] the action now
It's time to deliver and so he said I went out started trying to sell it to agents and they all would read it
They'd say you know. This is predictable. This is stupid. This is sappy
He said I wrote down all the things they said and I read them the night of the oscars when we want
Is really good right?
The Greatest Revenge is massive success
They said so what happened was he said I kept going trying to sell it trying to sell it nobody going. I'm broke
I'm starving
he said finally I meet these guys they read it and they [believed] in the script and they love it and they offer me a
Hundred and Twenty five thousand dollars from my script. [I] said oh my God you [must] been out of your mind
[he] said I was I said just one thing though guys you got a deal based on one thing
They said what's that? He said? I got a star in it. They went
What are you talking about? You're a writer so no I'm an actor. There's no. No you're a writer
So no, no I'm an actor that [is] my story, and I am Rocky said I got to play it
You know I got to be the head person. I got me the starring role this
There's no way when I can pay hundred tWenty-five thousand dollars
Take some no-name and stick you in that throw our money away. We need a star
You know and they want to have Ryan O'neal play Rocky give you a picture
Can you imagine that's who they picked right? And so he said no way Ryan O'neal's and [Rocky]
I'm Rocky went to this whole thing right. They finally. He said they said, we'll take it or leave it
He said I left the room. I said if that's what you believe you [know] get my script he left
Here's the man with no money none
totally broke offered
$125,000 more money in his lifetime he walked away because he knew his real what?
knew his real life and
Why I wanted he was committed to it
So he said they called him a few weeks later
And they came he brought it back and they offered him a quarter of a million dollars not to star in his own movie
He turned it down
$250,000 they came back their final offers three hundred and twenty five thousand dollars they wanted this thing
he said not without me, and they said no they finally compromised and they gave him thirty five thousand dollars and
points in the movie because I said if this is going to happen then you're going to take the risk with us and
The bottom line is we don't think [it] [will] work, but at least we won't spend a bunch of money on you
And they only spent a million dollars to make Rocky and it grows [200] million dollars at the time
It was done pretty well, but what's interesting about this is [here's] he I said what you do mean even 35,000
It's not a quarter of a million. That's a lot of money when you don't have 25 bucks
[I] said, what's the first thing you did?
I [figure] you went out and partied or something said I went to that liquor store for three straight days and hope that the man
had my dog
Frequented the store because I want to buy back my dog
That was so cool, right?
That was really cool. [I]
Said what happened. He said third day. I was there this guy walks by and I see him. I can't believe it. There's my dog
And I looked at her
I said sir remember me, and [he] said [it's] [been] about a month [and] a half
[I] thought this would all come about he said member me, and I'm the guy who sold you the dog I go yeah, yeah
I love the dog. He said look. He said I was so broke. I was starving. He's my best friend
I'm sure you loved him too, but I gotta happen black please I beg of you
He's all people hundred dollars to the dog. I know he paid me 25
I'll give you 100 the man said absolutely not no way. [he's] my dog now
You can't buy him back right and so I said you know tony you know they say no [you're] [out] [come] I said yeah
He said I knew it and he said I kept changing my approach, so I went
[$500] for the dog
The guy said absolutely no way
he said
$1,000 for my dog
Guy said no amount of money nervous, then we're gonna get this dog for you
So, [what'd] you do? He said? I knew my outcome right because he listened the same skip to him
He says I take massive action. He said I got my dog
I just kept changing my approach, so I got it as a what it cost
You [fifteen] [thousand] [dollars] and a part in Rocky the [guys] [in] Rocky
Either that dog in Rocky, but kiss that slice real dog, right?
That's the dog he bought a bank
So he put his dog in the movie and he put the guy in the movie [paid] 15 grand well he had
35,000 [not] pretty cool pretty awesome
So there's always a way if you're committed
Just kind of keep changing your brunch, [but] somewhere along the line you [changed]
You stopped being you you let people [stick] a finger in your face and tell you you're no good
And when things got [hard] you started looking for something to blame like a big shadow
Let me tell you something you already know
the world ain't all sunshine and rainbows
It's a very mean and nasty place
And I don't care how tough you are it will beat you to [your] knees and keep you there permanently if you let it you
Me or nobody is Gonna hit as hard as life
But it ain't about how [hard] you hit
It's about how hard you can get hit and keep moving forward how much you can take and keep [moving] forward
That's how weird it is done
Now if you know what you're worth the glottic [guilt] what you're worth
but you got to be willing to take the hits and [not] pointing fingers saying you ain't where you wanna be because of [him] or
[her] or anybody
Cowards do that in that [ain't] you you're better than that
Thank you guys so much for watching I'd love to know what did you think of this video?
What kind of motivation did you get from it? What was your favorite clip and why leave it down the comments below?
[I'm] gonna join in the discussion. Thank you again for watching [I] believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in yourself and whatever your one word is much love. I'll see you soon